今じゃ2冊です冷蔵庫から出しただけ
キンキンに冷えて薬剤師って書いてみますストロングゼロで結構になりました
結構どんなんですけれどもどうせ買ったんだったらなんか美味しい飲み方アレンジ
レシピのがあったらいいなと思いますねこちら今回準備させていただきましてちょっと
スペースを空け
させていただきます3段目からちょっと怖いですを付けて下さいだ助けてくださいっ
[音楽]
あと一本余ってしまいました
どうぞ
おっ
これ
これ違う話がそれました
今回買ってきたのはこちらとロッドはかき氷機でございますこれただのかき氷器じゃ
なくてを買いまんどがで言ってるふわっふわの先ゴリが作る機械の理由なんですよ
今回もう気づきでしょ南女するかと言いますと銀金に弾いてやラスト60このまま飲む
にはもうちょいねー
ええええええ
好きで今回ですねストロングゼロを使って彼に氷を作ってみようと思います
対応しだってかき氷にれもうじゃれでしょそれがもうその欠きゴール自体がでもう頭
ですからそして
ストロングゼロ含まれているということはオスだけなんですよ果たしてそんな二はテロ
ストロングゼロれもう夏季号で食べたら美味しいのかどうかそして酔うのかどうか
継承していきたいとおもいます
ん
f
なんか不思議なことにね毎日飲んでるわけじゃないんですけども定期的にストロング
ゼロ飲むとほんとに
美味しいですよさすが sega 閖上サンバーバンでございますでは早速準備して
いこう
これは希望だぜええこらー
今そうだねこれ釣り時計
うーんめっちゃ超えちゃったという
pon
[音楽]
持った
[拍手]
ん
いっ
もうほぼ1日家はさすがに凍ってると思うよね何に部以外の行きたいって氷づらくに何
な
コウタは凍ったわわー ua
ちゃんこれは強気な人はことはまあこっちを from するか
うーんキラキラキラキラ人でさあなどと言ってる間にしっかりとできました
ロングセラー郡モードですこれがまずいわけないでしょえこれやばい俺
悪魔のアカーランドす
5クー子それなら食べたさっき氷がめちゃくちゃにをやるみたいなそんなというのも
できるかもしれんですよ今日は様子で早速作ってみたいと思います
よかったねーブーブー d
パリーメッツブレちょっといる大丈夫人たぶんきました
ブーブ格好じゃねぇこれで蹴って増えていきます
ええええ
確率はくれちゃうこれこれこれやばいやばいやばい
もういいんじゃないでしょうかはーい
[音楽]
ダーという感染してしまいましたストロングゼロかき氷でございますつっこんな俺の
場面でちょっと味見してみましょう
いただきます
[音楽]
にがなんかレモンの爽やかさと天海がなくなってちょっと苦いです2階はこれ
アルコール9%なんでこいつあれこれ9%の強い感じだけがちょっと登っちゃってます
ねすごい品 a 4ですっと入ってくるんでこれで4みたいな角があるんですけど
barco 9%ポケットまあこいつ目2ちょっとシロップかけます
コレコレといいますうんっ
んまぁやばいなんてあもう150口だけとも言わず
これでどうだ誰がこんなポップ熱をトロンベゼロだと思いますかいやーこれは
[音楽]
アルコールなしアルコールがないや耐えて売ってる普通の美味しいかき氷その分
ヴァネスや惚れ気づかんな
ばーんわー
ん
これ本当に酔えるんまあああ
でも兄がいたまににが今でもやっぱり
んいっかーなんかだんだん化けの皮が剥がれてきたぞにが数3飲むのが一番ええ
[音楽]
bl gl パッケージ